Alexander bastrakin reported on the
first results of the investigation of
the
attack on the Crimean Bridge
the
data from the forensic analysis and also
operation
analysis says that the explosion on the
8th of October was a terrorist attack
terrorist attack aimed at destruction of
civil critically important
infrastructure of Russia it's also
obvious that the masterminds and
perpetrators are Ukrainian Security
Services
key of regime
has been using terrorist attacks for a
long time now
this is the assassination of public
figures scientists journalists both in
Ukrainian and Russia
this is terrorist attacks on uh shelling
of Donetsk and other cities
these are acts of nuclear terrorism
we're talking about
artillery and Rocket strikes against
zaparosia Nuclear Plant
Ukrainian secret Services also attempted
three attacks against Corsica nuclear
plant in Russia and they have been
blowing up high power lines leading to
this power plant and as a result of the
third attack three lines such lines have
been destroyed and
thanks to Urgent measures the serious
damage was prevented
however
there are a number of other terrorist
attacks and attempted terrorist attacks
against uh
power infrastructure and gas
Transportation power
Transportation infrastructure including
attempts to blow up Turkish stream
all of this has been
proven through objective means and also
through evidence given by people who
were detained
as
as we're aware
the
there are
um
attacks against International gas
Transportation pipelines in Baltic seas
and we of course are very familiar with
the beneficiary ultimate beneficiary of
these attacks
in this way cave regime through its
actions placed itself in line with
International terrorist organizations
with most audios terrorist organizations
leaving such crimes without response is
simply impossible this morning
on the proposal of the ministry of
defense and the general staff
we have conducted a massive High
Precision weapon strike
from the sea and from Land aimed at
Ukrainian military infrastructure
communication infrastructure and so on
in
case of continuation of terrorist
attacks on our territory we will respond
in a very harsh Manner and we will
respond respond in level with the level
of threats opposed against Russian
Federation nobody should have any doubt
thoughts about this and I'm asking the
Minister of Defense to provide a report
dear colleagues good afternoon
you're aware that yesterday the head of
the investigation okay there we have it
Vladimir Putin as I was saying holding a
meeting with the Russian Security
Council following those attacks on
Ukraine across Ukraine this morning and
the attack on the bridge linking Russia
to Crimea over the weekend let's bring
Indiana magnet in Moscow Diana your
reaction to what you've just been
hearing
well it's a justification isn't it for
these uh strikes across Ukraine this
morning he was
um Talking To The Head of the
investitative committee last night
Alexander pestrykin who told him that
they thought the sbu the Ukrainian
intelligence Behind these attacks and he
says that
um it is uh Ukraine now who is acting in
line with other International terrorist
organizations that they've committed uh
high-profile attacks on individuals on
public figures on journalists he didn't
say who he thought that those were but
of course the Russians blame the
Ukrainian sbu for the attack on Daria
dugina
um the uh sort of
pro-war
journalist daughter of one of the main
philosophers who's very Pro this whole
operation in donbass Alexander Dugan
here and he said that all of this uh
leaving the crimes of the key of regime
unansoned is just not possible and
therefore they have struck
with long-range High Precision weapons
all across Ukrainian energy military and
Communications targets which we saw of
course this morning I think the message
there is always to his own domestic
audience that when Russia strikes Russia
targets with high Precision of course it
is targeting military points rather than
civilians but you see the pictures
coming out of cities across Ukraine this
morning and that is clearly not the case
there have clearly been civilian
casualties as there have been all along
this horrific almost eight months of
Russia's so-called special military
operation but this is a significant
uptick and a response as he says to the
targeting of key Russian infrastructure
and Russia made it President Putin made
it very clear that if there were further
attacks on uh Russia that they would
their response would be very harsh
um Vladimir Putin has been egged on
essentially by the pro-war side of his
patriotic establishment over the last
weeks really since the kharkiv
counter-offensive where Ukraine managed
to start recapturing territory to do
more and certainly that was the case
after the Kirch Bridge attack on
Saturday and now we're hearing from the
sort of military blogosphere and from
key people who've been criticizing at
least the defense Ministry to detect to
date that they are satisfied for example
Rams and kadiroff the Chechen leader who
has sent a lot of his men into fight in
donbass said now I am now I am 100
satisfied with the special military
operation we had Alexander cots who's a
well-known and hugely followed military
reporter here who's in Ukraine in
donbass saying so over a video of the
attacks in in Kiev and you can hear
screams on the audio he said so who's
standing Outsider a photo of the Crimean
Bridge being attacked and posing for
photos now because that's what came on
social media over the weekend people in
Kiev standing in front of a a postage
stamp showing the Crimean Bridge
attacked and that has gone down badly
obviously with uh on on state media here
so I think for all of those people
clamoring for a tough response this is
what Vladimir Putin has delivered this
morning the question is does he have the
capabilities actually to continue to
deliver this going down the line he said
and it's this is really a message to his
domestic audience we will respond very
harshly if further attacks come against
Russian infrastructure he was talking
about the fact that he says there have
been three uh attempted strikes at the
Kursk nuclear power station he said that
before he says that they're a bit in
other attempts on infrastructure and
certainly there have been attacks On the
Border Town of Belgard which Russia
hasn't really responded to that much
before
but Vladimir Putin is trying to show
that he's a strong guy and that he will
respond toughly and this morning in
Ukraine he has